a
[Música]
y
la última encuesta realizada por el
observatorio venezolano de los servicios
públicos en las 10 ciudades más
importantes del país revela que durante
el confinamiento por la pandemia del
hobby 19 la falla de los servicios
públicos como agua electricidad y
telecomunicaciones se han agudizado
según el estudio la falta de agua
potable es el servicio que amasa que es
a los venezolanos en este momento un 67
por ciento no recibe suficiente para
mantener los niveles de higiene y de
prevención del cobi 19 en cuanto a la
electricidad los estados más afectados
son los fronterizos como colombia como
son el táchira y el zulia un 57 por
ciento de sus habitantes dijeron que
tienen o sufren constantemente de
fluctuaciones y de apagones en cuanto a
las telecomunicaciones la encuesta
también refleja que sólo un 34 por
ciento de la ciudadanía en venezuela
tiene funcionando el servicio de
internet y en cuanto a la telefonía
móvil el 58 por ciento de los
consultados
dijo que el servicio de data apenas les
permite mantenerse comunicados e
informados
[Música]
con la pandemia a hablar de
confinamiento supuso también hablar de
desigualdad quédate en casa no es un
lema que todo el mundo puede acatar
especialmente en contextos de pobreza en
los que también existen grandes
dificultades para cumplir con las
medidas básicas de higiene y autocuidado
hace unas semanas en plena pandemia una
imagen se hizo viral era la de unos
niños indígenas en verán lavando su
tapabocas en un charco de un conocido
parque de bogotá otro ejemplo en
buenaventura principal puerto de
colombia el 23 de junio durante 14 días
el 70% de la población se quedó sin agua
el agua un derecho y sin embargo son
cortes habituales también en el pacífico
en el choco harold ramírez secretario de
educación del departamento denunció que
los colegios no tienen ni
infraestructura ni internet ni agua
potable las 24 horas del día como para
enfrentarse al covent 19 una pobreza
energética que hace difícil evitar
brotes cuando la vuelta a clases está
prevista para septiembre
[Música]
marruecos es uno de los países más
afectados por la pandemia de kobe 19 la
crisis económica hace estragos y son
muchas las familias que no tienen
recursos para pagar las facturas de
energía tras decretarse el todavía
vigente estado de emergencia sanitaria
en marzo el gobierno aseguró que no
había no habría cortes de suministro
eléctrico ni de agua por impago pero
ahora las compañías privadas que operan
en el país se han retomado la lectura de
los contadores y ante la evidente
imposibilidad de pago para las más de
seis millones de familias que quedaron
sin sustento económico el estado ha
anunciado que se hará cargo de los dos
primeros tramos de cada contador
eléctrico pero esto resulta insuficiente
además si se tiene en cuenta que el
próximo 7 de septiembre vuelve a
arrancar el curso escolar a distancia y
a falta de medios para pagar la factura
de la luz se suma la necesidad de contar
con conexión a internet y de tener
dispositivos electrónicos para seguir
las
lo que pone en peligro el derecho a la
educación de muchos niños
[Música]